hey what's up guys it's Marcus browning
here from mkbhd and welcome back to a
step back in mkbhd videos this is raw
unedited audio quality from the alto
edge gooseneck gn3 microphone that i've
used in my past 80 or so mkbhd videos
you'll notice when it's unedited there
is quite a bit of background noise
there's a little bit of popping a little
bit of static in the background I did a
lot of editing with Camtasia Studio 6
and audacity to get this out to make it
much easier to understand what I'm
saying but what you're hearing right now
is completely unedited not touched peer
straight from the microphone audio the
purpose of this video of course is not
to demonstrate the quality of this
microphone but to give you guys a look
at the newest microphone and the newest
microphone that will be utilized by
mkbhd is the editors keys sl150
microphone very nicely and kindly
provided by the folks at editors keys I
will just be giving you a sample of what
it sounds like today before giving you
my full comprehensive hardware review of
the microphone so if you haven't already
go ahead and click to watch this video
and the highest available resolution
this will not only increase the video
quality but you'll be able to hear the
nuances of the microphone much better so
if you're already listening in HD there
you go you're hearing the raw quality of
this microphone and without further ado
let me introduce you guys to the editors
Keys sl150 and welcome back yeah what
you're hearing now guys is the raw
unedited audio quality of the editors
Keys sl150 mic
which means I'm using absolutely no
software to edit this and make it better
this is actually straight from the USB
microphone you notice there's no more
background noise as there was with the
XLR microphone and the quality is much
crisper because it is actually using a
pop filter on the microphone and it's
also a little crisper because it is a
condenser mic so as you can imagine if
this is raw unedited quality you can
only imagine what I can do using
audacity and using Camtasia Studio
six to find this audio tune quality and
just make it pretty much as good as it
can be so literally you heard it here
first this is audio quality again from
the link in the description you can
check out that microphone this is an
editor's Keys microphone a USB mic with
a pop filter and there are plenty more
reviews surrounding the equipment I use
to cover this audio base pretty much
coming up in the next few weeks so
thanks for watching this and initial
impressions of the microphone and you'll
be able to check out much more in the
future so again thank you for watching
peace